speaking of other screwy government
things Joe Biden finally finally he's
talking about the Border I think he's a
little confused about this title 42
situation take a look in fact the
previous administration used a rule
called title 42 to deal with to deal
with the pandemic a rapidly to rapidly
expel people who crossed the border it
was designed to deal with a pandemic but
it's used as a means to expel people at
the border people turned away under
title 42 and there are not and and and
they're not barred from trying to come
back they've been turned away they go
back they try again they try again well
you know they can and they do try to
re-enter the United States again and
again which makes the problem that
borders at the border even worse
man is it just me or is it getting
harder and harder to listen to him
because he has no idea what he's saying
actually about two minutes after that he
turned to Kamala and called her
president Harris and you could see that
when they locked eyes the shame in her
face of this absolute farce uh Carol
they're not going to do anything on the
border right like they just want more
and more people to come the other thing
that he announced was he's going to give
these people an app or access to an app
so that they can get in line in effect
he also compared the migrant situation
below our Southern border uh to the
Holocaust which probably not the really
most apt comparison right especially
because he did add don't come to the
border to be coming so like at the
Holocaust would hear it like don't come
do not get on the ships
um you know it's so just
um disheartening to me that Republicans
will not fight on the border it is such
a popular issue to stop the flow of
illegal immigration at our Southern
border and I just continue not to
understand why Republicans won't make it
a political issue it is not racist it is
not in any way racist it is it is
absolutely about the rule of law and you
know I say this of course as an
immigrant as somebody who had to wait to
come into the United States as a refugee
and I don't understand why Republicans
won't use it last month Chuck Schumer
said that he wants to legalize every
single person in the U.S legally not
like dreamers who are brought here with
kids no every single person and yet that
wasn't used in ads in Georgia for the
Herschel Walker runoff um that would
have been a really powerful ad and so I
we could blame Biden and we can blame
down democrats for the mess the
continuing mess but until Republicans
step up and grow a pair and start
fighting on this it won't change we're
just going to continue to have this flow
Buck are we missing something on the
media side of this thing I mean you
probably saw last week they had this
video out of the El Paso Airport with
just you know dozens and dozens if not
hundreds of illegal aliens just sleeping
at the airport and it's like nobody's
gonna cover that on mainstream media you
know we showed it you probably talked
about it but it never bubbles up and
because of that the average person
doesn't have a freaking clue what's
going on and then they hear Chuck
Schumer say make everyone legal and it
sounds nice and people are stupid like
it's basically something like that
we talk about it but I think we also
sometimes on the right get pulled down
into the weeds of oh well it's title 42
and they're going to change and they're
going to do some shifting of resources
to they want as many illegals to come
into the country as possible yes they
want to legalize all of the illegals all
of them who are in the country they want
to make it illegal to call them illegals
you'd like more sane takes on our insane
World check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live roundtables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell